exciting title eh today we're going to
be learning how to render these
it's called a circle and yes i did print
that
so circles seem like they should be
really easy to render
but they're not see the thing is modern
day gpus and graphics apis such as
directx opengl vulcan metal all of that
stuff they like to deal with triangles
and that's great if you're trying to
render a triangle or like a rectangle
because that's composed of two triangles
or even some kind of like 3d mesh that
works great but circles
circles are round
circles are smooth circles are soft i
guess i'm not sure if they're
necessarily soft but i imagine they are
they have this like nice smooth edge so
how are you supposed to have a smooth
edge if you're rendering triangles
jagged line straight line triangles that
just doesn't seem to work very well so
that's why i thought i'd make this video
we're going to learn all about how we
can actually
render those smooth soft circles and
we're going to be achieving this by
simply taking like the triangles out of
the equation we're not going to try and
create our circle out of actual geometry
we're just going to create like a canvas
for ourselves and then write a shader
that will actually create a nice smooth
soft circle for us but before we jump
into that is there a way that we could
just render the circle out of triangles
and of course we can in fact that's a
pretty common and popular way we could
just simply create a triangle fan that
goes all around our circle but then we
have this problem of but how many
triangles do we use because if we use
too few then we'll essentially end up
with like a hexagon or an octagon
something that obviously has very jagged
edges and to really make this smooth
especially if you zoom the camera right
into that or if the camera just gets
really close to that geometry to make it
actually look smooth you would have to
use a lot of triangles now modern day
gpus are pretty good at dealing with
triangles but it's still not exactly
ideal and what if you didn't want like a
filled in circle what if you just want
like an outline of a circle like a
like a non-filled in circle i don't know
what to call that well then instead of
triangles kind of going from the center
outwards you could just use lines going
around the perimeter of the circle but
again you have this problem of but how
many lines do i use the more lines i use
the kind of higher resolution that
circle becomes the smoother it becomes
it's kind of a similar problem that you
might have if you're modeling like a
sphere in blender or a 3d program or
something you you want kind of more
segments but that just increases the
density of the mesh now that's not to
say that you should never render circles
with triangles or with lines in fact
that's something that we actually do in
hazel mostly for like debug graphics
where like the the actual fidelity of
the circle might not matter as much so
for example here we're using it to just
visualize like the bounds of a point
light so that we can see how big it is
and then the last kind of type of circle
you might want to render is like a
doughnut essentially it's like a really
thick kind of outline of a circle for
that you could switch to using a
triangle strip instead of like a
triangle fan and then you could still
kind of draw that geometrically that's
perfectly fine but if your goal is to
have really nice smooth
soft i keep saying soft round kind of
circles then it's clear that this kind
of geometric approach is just not really
what you want to do so let's dial back
circles for a little bit because they
really shouldn't be this complex in fact
they're one of the simplest shapes we
can describe because if we were to
mathematically describe them they're
simply like a point and then the radius
the size of the circle in fact in many
ways they're actually much simpler than
a rectangle that has like you know four
bounds this is just a point and a radius
so why is it so difficult to render well
again it's because gpus love triangles
but what if we just don't worry about
triangles for the sake of this what if
we just create for ourselves a little
canvas upon which we can render a
beautifully smooth and soft circle we'll
kind of create this little canvas for
ourselves and then we can write a custom
shader like a pixel shader or a fragment
shader same thing that will simply
render our nice smooth circle using that
kind of mathematical principle and then
because it's like a custom shader we can
really do anything we want there we can
create a nice smooth faded transition we
can make the fade really large for a
stylistic effect we have all of this
control because we're controlling
the entire rendering of the circle
within that gpu shader code and that is
precisely what we're going to do now
what i'm going to do for this video is
i'm not going to actually go over the
implementation of how to do this from
start to finish instead we're going to
just focus on the actual glsl shader
code although if you use hlsl or msl
this should be very easy to adapt we're
just going to focus on that shader code
using a website called shader toy and
i'll go pretty deep into it and explain
everything if you guys want to see some
kind of actual integration video maybe
using opengl or something like that
where i show you how to actually take
that that from shader toy and integrate
it properly into an engine let me know
in the comment section below but
otherwise i think that this should be
pretty easy to integrate pretty much
anywhere all you really need to be able
to do is just render quads and those
quads need to be they need to have some
kind of like good local space attached
to them so for example in hazel the
quads the vertex positions of the quads
go from negative point five to positive
point five so they have that kind of one
by one meter like unit range being able
to access that like local coordinate
space within your fragment shed is going
to be really important as we'll see
later but those are like the draw calls
that you need to issue and this is very
easy and probably recommended to
actually integrate into like a batch
renderer i have a battery under a series
on my channel definitely check that out
if you haven't already there we're
rendering quads but you can also easily
extend that to render circles instead
because the circles are just quads but
using a different shader so they will
need to be in like a separate draw call
since they're using a different shader
to the to the quads that are being
rendered in the batch renderer but all
of your circles can easily be batched
together into a single draw call as well
even if they're like filled in not
filled in doughnuts whatever anyway i
think that's enough talking let's dive
in and take a look at how we can render
circles okay so to explore this we're
gonna be using a website called shader
toy shader toy.com if you haven't heard
of this highly recommend it lots of very
exciting shaders and it's a great way to
learn more about shaders and a lot of
the math that goes into rendering
graphics in general we're not going to
be doing anything as cool as like some
of the stuff that we see here that
actually has the label warning because
it's so complicated but over here on
like the right side we have this new
button we can press it and we'll just be
taken to a blank new shader let me make
this a little bit bigger for you guys
maybe like that and we can start talking
about this okay so what is shader toy
how does this help us with our circles
so what you're seeing here is very
simple and it's it's basically the same
place that we're at when we're rendering
our circles it is a canvas this is
simply like a full screen quad that is
being drawn here that covers this entire
surface and this is the fragment shader
that is shading these pixels so this
code over here runs for every single
pixel that we have over here it uses
some built-in variables that we can see
in shader inputs such as like time and
resolution and that is what produces
these lovely colors that we are seeing
here so let's kind of reduce this to
basically nothing because we don't
really need any of this like boilerplate
code
we can just set the frag color to be
like a constant white or something alt
enter to compile and there we have this
right so pretend that this area over
here is in fact that quad that i
mentioned that we have to draw to
act as like the canvas for our circle
now the first issue that you can see
here is that this is not a square right
it's a rectangle it's 960 by 540 that's
a 16 9 aspect ratio so really it's not
it's not one to one which means that if
we were to mathematically draw a circle
here it would actually fill up the
entire width and height and it would be
more of an ellipse now let's talk a
little bit about why that would happen
why it would be an ellipse and like how
we're even going to draw the circle in
the first place so we basically want the
ability obviously to draw these circles
anywhere in our world whether that be
some kind of screen space element like
for ui purposes or if we want it to be
just in the 3d world potentially or in a
2d world right it's on world space as
well the way that we achieve that is by
having like a game world and then just
drawing this kind of
uh square this quad somewhere in the
world right so again if we draw this
canvas in which we're going to draw a
circle if we draw that
at a particular place in our world then
clearly the circle is also going to be
there so in other words the position
isn't controlled within this shader it
shouldn't be that's just more of like
the actual physical geometry will appear
somewhere else however the way this is
going to work is that inside this kind
of square we're going to have a sort of
local space and that local space is
going to define what area is basically
inside our circle and what area is not
so our goal is to draw something like
this right this is a very terrible
circle
but it's a circle that i got to do that
again okay slightly better so we have
this kind of circle within this quad
that we're drawing and of course this is
kind of our two triangles that are
actually being drawn here so if that is
the case then we need some kind of local
coordinate system within this actual
square within this quad so that we can
address each pixel
we can't have this be something in world
space we need to be local to this actual
geometry right preferably where the
middle would be zero
right the origin and then the width and
the height shouldn't really matter but
they need to be some kind of constant
unit such as one so we can have negative
one for the left positive one for the
right and then maybe something like that
now it's common inside like game engines
and the way that we're doing this in
hazel as well it's common to kind of
stick to a unit
right like you want to pick your units
and you want to deal with real world
units such as meters not necessarily
arbitrary like numbers right because
that doesn't make much sense so pretty
much everything we render all the
primitives in hazel are one by one meter
right what that means is that when we
render like a quad or a circle we want
it to be one meter by one meter right so
again that will apply to a circle as
well so what that means is that well if
these were negative one to one then that
would be two meters right uh one minus
minus one is two so instead we basically
when we actually build up this geometry
right just like we did in the batch
renderer series if you if you take a
look at that video series you'll see
that um we basically have a range of
negative 0.5 to 0.5 when we make these
actual physical vertices i'm getting a
little bit
sidetracked here like this is this is
more to do with the implementation but
it's important because these are the
units that we're actually going to be
using the coordinate system will be
using inside the shader so it's
important to understand that long story
short we have two triangles that we draw
right to make up this kind of uh quad
right and their vertices are negative
point five on this corner and positive
point five on this corner meaning that
this is point five for x and y that's
negative point five for x and y and
obviously something like over here would
be 0.5 positive x and negative 0.5 on y
and that of course achieves a size of 1
by 1 which is what we're looking for and
circles are no different since we have
this kind of absolute unit range that
means that if we were to use like a
scale matrix to distort this so a
non-uniform scale if i apply a
non-uniform scale like in the transform
component inside my entity in my game
engine then it's going to potentially
make this uh this square not a square
anymore so it could scale this up right
and then the vertex shader will apply
that scale now the thing with this is
that these local units should still stay
the same right they obviously these
vertices that we'll that we'll be using
will still be 0.5 to 0.5 this will be
0.5 negative 0.5 meaning that our circle
will end up being quite long which might
actually be what you want i think you
should be able to distort your circles
scale them non-uniformly you know who
says we need to have circles we can have
ellipses too there is room to love them
as well so anyway i just think it's
really important to just realize that
like you know these vertices or this
kind of local coordinate system that we
use that is kind of independent of where
the vertices actually end up in our in
our rendering because there's just so
much at play there including the
transform of the geometry but also like
the view and projection of the camera
but back in shader toy all we are really
seeing is that final kind of canvas and
so our first task has to be to like
simulate something like this this
negative point five or negative one to
one bounds because if we don't do that
then
how we're going to draw our circle
locally so in this case in shader twice
case we have this uv coordinate in your
engine or in hazel i think it's actually
just a local kind of position that is
passed in as a vertex attribute which is
then sent into the fragment shader
during the rendering pipeline right so
in other words we actually send in like
negative point five or negative one i
think and then positive one on the other
side we actually send that in as a
vertex attribute that's what we use as
the basis for this but in this case we
can equally use a uv coordinate right
because a uv coordinate if we actually
take a look at this so if i just do frag
color dot rg equals uv
right it is just a number that is zero
on this side let me just maybe get rid
of the blue because it's probably a lot
more common to see it like like that so
if we get rid of the blue then you can
see the bottom left is zero zero the
right side here is one on the x-axis and
then we have the green being one on the
y-axis the the top left and then the top
right is just one on both axes right so
in other words we have a range here of
zero two one but the problem with this
is that it's in it's in a zero to one
range not like a negative one to one
range or a negative point five to point
five range we want zero to be in the
middle not in the bottom left corner
because we're going to be using that as
the origin point for our circle to
convert this zero to 1 into negative 0.5
to 0.5 we can simply just subtract 0.5
right and now you can see that the
middle the very middle of this actually
looks like where the black begins
because these colors are all negative
they get clipped to zero
and then here we have our actual color
but let's actually convert this into a
negative one to one range because that's
just going to be a little bit easier to
understand going forward so we could
surround this by parentheses and then
just multiply it by two so that takes
the negative point five makes it one and
it takes the positive point five also
makes it one then we have that range
here but you can also just do times two
minus one which is probably the more
kind of common way of seeing this
conversion and it mathematically gives
you the same result of course now the
next thing we have to deal with is the
aspect ratio because this kind of canvas
is not a square like we would have it's
a rectangle but that's also something
that's very easy to deal with because we
have this resolution variable over here
i can easily calculate the aspect ratio
here by just dividing x by i resolution
y this will give me around 1.78 for this
resolution here i'm literally just
dividing 960 by 540. so then if i take
this aspect ratio and i multiply just my
x u v coordinate by it it's going to now
make this in the range of negative 1.78
to positive 1.78 on the x axis
and then still keep it at negative 1 to
1 on the y y-axis right so now
i kind of more or less have an aspect
ratio correct uv coordinate and to
demonstrate this i could easily write
some code that will discard uh basically
any pixels or at least set them to black
in this case i don't know what's behind
there to discard but we'll basically set
anything
that is greater than uh one right to
just be black and actually we'll have to
do the same thing
uh for
less than because obviously we have
negative one on the other side so let's
just
write that maybe let's just bring this
up here and then if that if statement is
true
we'll just set it rgb to vec3 zero okay
so needs some more
uh parentheses
and there we go right so now you can see
we have this kind of letterboxing we
have these black bars on on on either
side because that is outside of the
range we didn't really have to do this
for the y axis because we know that's
negative one to one but anyway point is
that is how we can kind of make sure
that we're dealing with a square in the
middle
which has been the entire point thus far
now i realize this isn't really too
relevant to circles but hopefully this
is just some helpful general jell-o cell
advice maybe and also some shaded toy
tips so let's summarize what we've done
so far because it is possibly getting
complicated right so what we have now is
a this uv variable which in the middle
is zero zero that is the coordinate and
then on each of these kind of corners it
is negative one or positive one right so
in this case it's negative one on the x
and one on y right over here it's
positive 1 on both the x and the y axis
they're both both the x and the y
variables inside this uv variable so now
let's kind of take it back to what a
circle is mathematically so the way that
we define a circle is a point and then
also a size so a radius now the point is
irrelevant to any of this shader code
why because the actual location of the
geometry the transform of the geometry
is what determines where this circle
will be in our game world right or in
whatever world it is doesn't have to be
a game world so we can just forget about
that because in our case that point is
zero zero and it's in the middle now the
radius
that's important because what that's
going to define is how big our circle is
now as i mentioned earlier because this
goes through the render pipeline we do
in fact have a scale parameter that is
external to all of this we could draw a
quad on the screen this big or that big
and it has nothing to do with the code
that renders the quad it's everything to
do with the transform matrix and
specifically the scale within that
transform component so because of that
the size is kind of irrelevant because
again that's external if we want a
smaller circle we simply draw a smaller
quad meaning that like this actual thing
here is smaller so really what we're
trying to do
is maximize the radius within the quad
right i want it to go all the way to the
edge what does that mean well for a quad
that has a range of negative one to one
it means the radius should be one right
because the diameter in that case will
be two and it will perfectly fill our
quad or in this case our render area
that we have over here so to summarize
we just want a circle where zero zero is
the origin meaning that we don't even
really need to consider the origin and
then one is the radius it's like a unit
circle it's all very very simple so now
that we're aware of like the
mathematical representation of this
circle how do we actually draw it well
when it comes down to it all we're
really trying to do is look at this kind
of image and then determine which pixel
is inside the circle and which pixel is
outside of the circle because if the per
if the pixel is inside the circle then
we should shade it with whatever color
we want the circle to be to start off
with we'll be rendering filled in
circles and then if the pixel that we're
processing is outside of the of the
range of this circle then we probably
want to just discard that pixel or in
shader toy's case because we can't
really blend with anything underneath
without like creating a new layer and
doing all of that complex stuff so we'll
just render that as black but in your in
your own kind of game engine you
probably want to discard that pixel or
like set the alpha to zero or something
like that so since circles are in fact
just that radius what we really need is
a way to calculate the distance between
this origin point and any given pixel
because remember every single pixel over
here in this image runs through this
line of code so for every pixel we need
to calculate its distance from the
origin point so from zero so just its
distance and then see if it is less than
the radius
because if it's less than the radius
which is one then perfect it's inside
the circle otherwise it's outside so how
do we calculate the distance of each
pixel well do we have some kind of
coordinate system we can use and of
course we do the coordinate system is
that uv variable that we made so the uv
variable is the coordinate of each pixel
on our screen at its at its given
position and that uv coordinate is just
like a
two-dimensional vector which if we just
measure the length of the vector because
0 is the middle then we will in fact get
the length of the vector being the
distance between the origin and that
pixel in this kind of local space so how
do we get the length of a vector well
there is of course a length function so
let's go ahead and calculate the
distance
as length of uv and then what i'll do is
we don't really need this anymore i
might just leave it down here but what
i'll do is i'll output the uh frag color
as being just vec3 distance so the rgb
values are just going to be this
distance and this is what we end up with
now i might just get rid of these uh
black bars over here so you can see the
full image but of course because we have
this aspect ratio
it still conforms to be like a proper
circle and not an ellipse right if i got
rid of this then that's where we get
that stretching and so that's why i
added it now another common way to
actually calculate the length in glsl
which you may have seen is by
calculating the dot product of the
vector with itself
right which gives us this and then
square rooting that result
right i've seen that a lot as well now
this and this is technically identical
if you actually open up the glsl
documentation and you take a look at
what the length function does you can
see that it literally like squares each
component here and then square roots it
right it does the same thing and of
course a dot product is going to take
like the first x component and then
multiply it with the x component of the
second vector that you're dotting and
then add you know y zero times y one but
when you're dotting a vector with itself
then obviously it's just x times x plus
y times y right which ends up being the
same as x squared plus y squared and to
calculate the vector's magnitude or this
length you then square root that right
so effectively it's doing the same thing
i'm not sure if maybe some people think
this is faster i honestly don't know
because i'm sure that length is probably
i don't know maybe they do it to save a
function call length doesn't necessarily
have to be calling these functions
anyway i don't know the point is i think
it makes a lot more sense to just write
length so let's talk about this distance
for a minute if you look at the image on
the left you can see the middle is black
right why is it black because at that
point the distance is zero the distance
between the middle right the origin and
a pixel very close by is going to be
very low that's why the value is so dark
and black in the very middle zero minus
zero is zero however as we get further
out it lightens up now here it kind of
hits white and then it remains white
it's still going up it's just that the
values get clamped back to one i don't
think this is like an hdr buffer or
anything capable of of storing numbers
above one right above 255 so because of
that it just kind of gets clamped but
you can actually see that if i like for
example uh take the color and i subtract
like 0.5 from it you can see that kind
of radius expands because i'm just i'm
just kind of bringing down that color
range so that we can actually see more
colors if that makes sense even though
we're just kind of looking at a
different range of colors okay so now
that we have this distance what can we
do with it and how does it help us with
our circle well clearly we seem to have
already rendered a circle the problem is
the color is not really constant also it
seems to kind of be almost the opposite
of what we want i would want the
outsides to be black and then the circle
in the middle to be white so to fix that
the first thing we can do is actually
invert this color just doing one minus
length is going to make it so that now
the middle is a one and then as we get
further out we go down to zero instead
of going up to one and then we actually
go negative and again if i go to
distance and i add like point five you
can see that expand because we're just
now visualizing kind of numbers that are
that are less than zero by shifting them
up to be above zero so that we can see
them but the problem with this is that
again we have this kind of nice smooth
gradient i don't want that i just want
the i just want the color to be either
either this or that right but to make
that happen it's really simple all i
have to do is say that if the distance
is greater than zero then i can for
example in this case because we're
setting the color to be the distance i
can set the distance to be one and then
we're basically done because now as soon
as we get above above zero and we're in
kind of positive number territory we
know that we are within the bounds of
our circle now if we look at this
mathematically in the form of a graph
let's see what's going on here so we
have this graph we have let's just label
this as x and y so our x-axis is going
to be the distance and then our y-axis
is the color because that's kind of like
our result right
now the thing with this is that we've
actually inverted this if you go back
here then you can see that we've
inverted the distance so in other words
uh let's maybe make this point over here
zero and then we'll make this like
negative 0.5 or something so what we
have is we have this kind of a value
here which is our distance it goes all
the way until it hits one and remember
one is kind of like the very center if i
get rid of this it will be a little bit
easier to understand one is this very
center and then as we get further out we
will eventually drop below zero so in
other words it's kind of like we're
going this way you can kind of read this
graph from right to left instead of left
to right but anyway point is we have
this value over here this is one a
distance of one because we've inverted
it so that's the middle of our circle
and then as we get further out this
distance decreases and then eventually
falls below zero so what we're kind of
doing at the moment is we're saying okay
well if it's above zero
then this is the value i want right i
just want it to be exactly one and of
course we should label this as one but
then as soon as we get below zero
on this kind of distance axis
then we immediately make it zero so this
is what we've kind of created here and
if we just connect the two dots here
then this is like what the graph would
look like we've basically gone from
having a linear graph like this to
something like this which is like a step
function basically like a square wave so
what we can actually do is instead of
using an if statement for this inside
glsl we can actually use this step
function because there is a function
called step and it matches the
mathematical step function and it
basically lets us just simply specify
like an edge like as if this is like a
cliff and this is the edge and then an
actual obviously value that we're
putting into this step function so if we
take a look at the json documentation
then you can see we have this step
function over here takes in two
parameters the edge which is the
location the edge of the step function
and x the value to be used to generate
the step function so again the edge is
in our case
0 because 0 is like the edge of this
cliff
and then what's going to happen is that
if we basically cross that edge it's
going to give us a 1 otherwise it's
going to give us 0 that's just how the
step function works so d will be like
the x variable that we pass in over here
that's going to be d the distance and
then the edge is just simply going to be
this like turning point zero so if we go
back to our shader let's go ahead and
use that so instead of using this if
statement i'm instead going to say so we
were actually setting distance to one so
let's just go ahead and try and set
distance
to be
step zero because the edge of course
goes first which is a little bit
confusing i never really liked that but
anyway we'll put in uh the edge and then
distance itself is going to be like the
x uh variable and if we compile that
then you can see we get exactly the same
result as before but now we're using
math
fun times but of course the thing that i
should definitely point out here is that
the step function
uh well that it's it's the same like it
uses branches so
um if you want to write code like if you
know a distance uh greater than zero set
distance one go ahead honestly because
the implementation is basically
identical the reason why i'm saying that
this is math is not because it's
literally multiplication you know
subtraction addition that kind of stuff
but because it's an actual like
mathematical function that we can use
for a lot more than just like that if
statement and it's just a little bit
more kind of generic i guess it's a
little bit more used in the industry so
that's basically it when it comes down
to like the simplest way to basically
draw like a filled in circle because
this color is white and this outside is
black you can also easily multiply this
with any color and you will get that
other color if i multiply white with
orange i'm going to get orange because
white is simply one
now what i could do if i was actually
trying to like blend this with existing
like you know to composite it on top of
like an existing color buffer or
existing pixels then i could instead of
affecting like rgb here and setting like
the background to zero or whatever i
could instead just have this affect the
alpha channel so in other words i could
set the alpha to be this and then
otherwise the alpha would be zero
instead right and if i did that it's not
really going to work here um and of
course you uh
you want to
actually do this right it's not really
going to work here and in this case you
would set the frag color the rgb to be
the actual color of the circle you don't
need to do any multiplication and then
you would just set the alpha to be like
the distance and that will be it but
this is shader toy there's nothing
underneath so i'll still keep treating
it as rgb okay so we have a way to
render a filter in circle but what if i
want like a doughnut or what if i want
like a really thin not filled in circle
how do i do that well in that case if we
go back to our diagram here i mean it's
it's it's very similar to what we have
now it's just that instead of allowing
this to be one for the entire duration
what i kind of want to do instead is
make it go back down to zero i kind of
want to do this right where this doesn't
exist anymore and then i basically have
a b1 meaning it's filled in those pixels
are filled in with some kind of color
for a short distance between 0 and like
0.1 and then it just goes back down to
0. so in other words if i try to write
this logically so like distance if
distance is greater than 0.1 right which
should be that kind of border that we're
looking at right so this is 0 this is
like 0.1
therefore if it's greater than 0.1 let's
reduce it back down to 0. if i was to
try and write that
like this as well
it's not going to work and the reason
the reason why it's not gonna work is
because the distance has already been
affected by that by that step function
we don't want that to happen we need the
actual real distance not the process
distance that will that is really just
used for color
so what we'll do is we'll change this to
be our color i'll just call it col color
and then that's going to be a vec3 um of
our kind of step here and then this
color is what we're going to set our
frag color to be now if i do something
like this i can actually use distance
and then maybe set the color you know to
be zero and then if i take a look at
that then of course it's going to give
us this where the distance here again is
like the kind of thinness of your circle
now can we do this using a step function
of course we can we just need to take
that existing color and multiply it by
a step and i'll wrap this in a vector3
as well we're going to take this value
as the as the edge of our step function
will pass in that existing distance
value however if we take a look at that
we still get the same result because
we're kind of doing a step the other way
if you take a look at this what we're
really doing is we're actually going
down like that instead of going up like
we were before so to fix that up we
actually need to reverse the result of
our step function by just inverting it
so one minus step and then we'll get
this same result now this is our
thickness parameter i might just bring
it up so that it makes more sense this
is going to be our thickness that's what
that edge is
and then what i can do for fun is just
actually assign that to be the x
coordinate of the mouse and we'll divide
it by i resolution dot x so that we get
it from pixel space into this kind of
screen space and then what i can
actually do is click and drag my mouse
and you can see it's actually going to
change the thickness of my circle pretty
cool now if i set this thickness
manually to something like 1 that will
result in having a filled in circle okay
brilliant looks really good but does it
and the answer is it doesn't why because
well we have this really hard edge and
the reason that's happening is because
everything's very like robotic there's
no kind of smooth fading it's just
literally a step function which we know
as soon as it hits a particular value it
drops right the function as we know
looks like this it's really sharp it
means that if we look at a group of
pixels
if this pixel is inside the circle it's
white and the pixel next to it is just
immediately black there is no kind of
smooth transition or fading that we
would want to reduce that aliasing and
the kind of rough edge there
so what can we do about it well ideally
we would kind of have a bigger
transition between these pixels where
instead of just going from white to
black instantly maybe we would go to
kind of like a gray which i'll just show
like this and then we'll go to black
right so in other words we kind of we we
smoothly fade from that one value from
white to black so can we do that well
yeah pretty easily actually because
turns out the step function has a
smoother cousin called smooth step so if
we take a look at smooth step in the
documentation you can see that it's it
basically does like it works the same
way as a step function but there are two
edges instead of one and the reason
there are two edges is because the
function looks something like this so
what you're specifying here is basically
the edge at which it begins and then the
edge at which this kind of smooth
interpolation ends so you could like
really stretch this out and make it that
big where these are the two edges or you
could be really like you know really
kind of not that smooth at all and make
make the edges closer together and
therefore you get like less less of a
long fade right and in fact if you make
the edges equal then there is like no
distinction between them which means it
is basically just a regular step
function so let's try that out what
we'll do is we'll go back to our code
and instead of using a step over here
i'm going to change it to be smooth step
and then now we have to decide between
what kind of two distances i guess are
we doing that kind of faded
interpolation now zero
zero is our absolute boundary right
because what we're doing is we're
rendering a quad and zero a distance of
zero in our code equates to being like
literally on the edge so we can't go any
anything out outside of that range
will simply not be rendered so we can't
actually extend the bounds that way we
have to do everything within this canvas
within our render area so what that
means is that this actually has to be a
larger value you can't go negative so if
we set it to something like i don't know
0.1 and take a look at what that looks
like well we get that's quite a big
distance so we get this kind of blurry
look right but if we set if we set it to
be something rather small then it starts
to look a lot better and in hazel i
think this value is set to
0.005 so if you really zoom in on that
or if you look at it in full screen then
you can see it actually looks really
good feel free to play around with this
i don't know like maybe 0.2 would be
better if it's like a larger because
there are more pixels just looking there
are more pixels to render so my quad hd
monitor this actually looks pretty good
but you should be able to see the
difference between using smooth step and
then regular step right i'll kind of
show you both examples in the video so
this kind of fade parameter is also
something that you could bring out so
float fade
and then you can kind of tweak that and
yeah you can you can of course make it
really big and then maybe use that as a
stylistic effect as well i'm gonna leave
it at point zero zero five but what
about for the inside circle so if the
thickness is like point one or something
the inside is still jagged can we use it
for that as well and the answer is of
course so this becomes thickness
minus fade and then thickness
and now we have a nice smooth result now
this is inverted
right so what we can actually do is kind
of change this a little bit where we
just flip the edges and then suddenly it
becomes
less of that and more of that right and
so to do that we can just basically move
this minus fade to be on the second edge
and then that will create this but then
we can just remove that inversion so
we'll just save that little one minus we
don't need it anymore and we can still
have our nice beautiful circle so there
we go we have a nice smooth circle we
can control the thickness using like the
mouse or something and everything looks
good there is one slight problem left
though because we did in fact do this
kind of smooth step now and we're
subtracting fade what that means is that
if we set the thickness to be one
because we want this to be a perfect
circle perfect filled in circle there is
in fact a hole in the middle and the
reason is because we're subtracting that
fade so thickness is one but we're
subtracting fade now to remedy this what
you could do if you wanted to is just
kind of add on the fade and then it will
go away or you can just arbitrarily set
this to like a larger number
right you could have an if statement
that says if it's one then maybe don't
even do this calculation that's also a
possible solution there's a few
solutions but i think what you could do
is just maybe always just add the fade
to the thickness and then what that
means is that like you might not be able
to make it as thin as possible anymore
because the thickness of
zero will give you a thickness of 0.005
but you probably wouldn't be doing that
anyway
and then you'll be able to perfectly go
to one like that now what you could also
do which i realized while editing this
video is instead of just adding on this
fade if i get rid of that and we get
that hole back instead of doing that
what you could do is just simply change
the way this fade is applied to the
smooth step so instead of subtracting it
from this side we could actually add it
to this side of the smooth step so to
the first edge that effectively gives us
the same kind of result the same kind of
behavior instead of subtracting it from
here we're adding it onto here which
still means that this edge is larger
than this edge but it just means that
we've kind of moved around the placement
of it so that it it does the same thing
as what i did in the video but this just
obviously looks a lot cleaner now
finally again with the color just just
take the color and then multiply it by
whatever you want so if i wanted like a
nice
maybe like orangey kind of color
there we go i'm just simply multiplying
that white by whatever i want and of
course i get my color so that is how we
can render some rather nice looking
circles i'll leave a link in the
description below to this shader toy
example that i've written here so from
here it should be pretty easy to take
this and integrate it into any kind of
game engine or just a graphics project
as i mentioned if you guys want to see
me integrate this into maybe like the
batch renderer series or into i'll have
to integrate this into get the game
engine series and hazel 2d anyway so
that video will definitely be coming out
but either way let me know in the
comments below if you enjoyed the video
please don't forget to hit the like
button also let me know what your
thoughts are regarding rendering circles
in the comments section below how are
you rendering circles maybe there's like
some other technique i'm not aware of
let me know hopefully this video was
helpful too if it was please consider
helping to support the channel by going
to patreon.com the channel your support
is what makes videos like this one
possible and you can also get access to
hazel and all of its source code thank
you guys for watching the video i hope
you have an amazing day and i will see
you next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you